what is up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
John Humphrey Katrina Alicia Katrina
John Greg are you gonna check out this
trailer for a new show that is
premiering on Amazon called dark web it
is based on the biography of Greg Alba
yes I'm gonna be hosting a panel at
comic-con at the Horten grand theater
Friday July 19th 1:30 p.m. Friday July
19th is when this show is premiering on
Amazon and I'm doing a panel for this
show so I felt it only be appropriate
that I know something about the show
other than some very brief things it's
an 8 episode web series it was
independently funded at the time and
it's sort of like black mirror esque so
it's an anthology series but there's a
lot of connective tissue - a semi sory
alized so I'm excited to check this out
the short synopsis that I received is a
genius programmers mysterious
disappearance leads to the reunion of
old friends and discovery that the
strange story she left behind may point
to an impending technological crisis I'm
excited for this I feel like the panel
should be primarily about me and how
great I am so if you happen to be at
Comic Con I would love it if you could
show up praise me and when you see me on
stage but you know downplay the other
actors and actually like the people who
are part on this show whatever what
you're really there for is me am i right
[Laughter]
let's watch this trailer beside I
finally get to see footage of the ship
hmm
[Music]
Michael hey Shep tonight she's like any
man used to all this rusted while he was
joined stuff how can no one know that
she she put real places in the story why
not just tell us what the hell's going
on first
she tried to blow the whistle Maurice
Gabriel unum she's here we have to find
her there's something going on
[Music]
let me start at the beginning no one
else will get hurt
the world's a bad place it's bad for you
like the way that we're all connected
now oh you remember that actresses name
Lana McKissack yeah yeah she went to
school with my sister really I saw her
at the LA Rockwell table on stage when
they did the on both series of Jurassic
Park Wow yeah it was great she was
awesome
nice let's talk about that for the next
five minutes yeah for sure Chloe you
know she and her boyfriend of YouTube
I'm not gonna lie
whenever we agreed to shout out or be a
part of something that we didn't have
direct involvement with the making of
and I haven't seen footage of it yet I
always get a little bit nervous it's not
like one too many times were like oh now
we've once got like an offer for a movie
and then we're like can we watch the
movie first and they were often isn't
like a good amount of money to actually
like cover it to review it and we had to
tell them I can't give you the review
you probably yeah
for the money this looks pretty damn
good right because of the fact that it
was independently create at first
there's some things with like audio in
some scenes it seemed very like indie
asked but beyond that it's like such a
nitpick every visual is a great
cinematography looks awesome this looks
intense and weird and creepy oh my god
I'm nervous editing I really promise
skin like it parts yeah I love that
yeah I can't wait to watch that looks
great and there's two people who have
been featured in this trailer I think
the other part I think I saw her briefly
but one of the main guys Michael
nardelie yeah it was the one who
approached me asking me to do this he's
been on the channel but
we're good friend has some of the best
ABS in the world I'm telling you he had
to change shirts and fry he didn't have
to be chose to change versa for me when
he came to be there I think he was
trying to seduce me
and let's just leave it at that Greg and
Michael I know I'll be hanging out with
at comic-con oh yeah and then my old
acting teacher I think Kimberly Bigsby
was in here too I mean she knows Michael
from the same laughing studio so I think
I just saw her briefly in here but
there's other famous players and Iommi
Gonzalez is going many places I hear
about her all the time
Nicholas Brendon Xander from Buffy
Hayley marine norm and I saw has been on
a blue million things right and then you
got an actor from lost in space a TV
show that came out Netflix hmm I know
I'm gonna say this perfectly sim bond
Gilly Lumbo I think it's like a more
than it's uh yeah don't worry
I'll ask her on stage yeah very
professional we're gonna nail it
oh yeah definitely yeah it's gonna be
it's gonna be wonderful
but now you got a lot of big players in
the unity an image Gabriel Luna here's a
new Ghost Rider and the new evil
Terminator so they got a lot of big
players I'm work for this I'm excited to
be a part of this panel and it's gonna
be really cool first I was like am i
excited now I'm definitely excited
reaction the show itself looks pretty
cool though and I like that it's a
contained anthology and knowing that
there's connective tissue now I'm
wondering like is the first episode
gonna be about this sort of central
figure than who and how like ma yeah
then how it affects all the different
characters but she knows over time in
different ways or sometimes like the
Naomi Gonzalez characters the main
connective tissue here yeah which seems
really cool to me because I think that
really helps separate it from something
like a black mirror because I know black
mirror deals so much for technology but
it seems like there's a very distinct
narrative they're actually trying to
tell here I think some of the actors
themselves have even directed some of
the episodes there's some female
directors tell me the camera is really
cool so yeah this is like such a great
show oh this is something I read when
they watch this was pitched to us
initially as like a sci-fi series but
part of what I loved as a horror fan was
that it doesn't look pretty aggressively
horror you with
creature vibes you know you've got these
like face tentacles you've got these
things with people pulling spiders out
of their ears and stuff like that
netting cockroach yes falling around
under that one girl's flesh like yeah it
looks like it may also have a lot of
different elements of body horror and
gross out horror and sci-fi for as well
as the technological paranoia hasman and
as someone who loves to dabble in the
dark web I'm finally excited that we're
gonna get a direct series this is not
unfriended dark web that was BS this is
the real dark web you can only watch
this on onion where the amount of
YouTube videos that we do not put up
always go on the dark web yeah go search
around for the real rejects there and
I'm hoping that you know when they get a
season 2 they can infuse us into their
series yeah when we when we start doing
snuff film reactions for sure oh hey
I've done them solo I are forgotten yeah
yeah those are most of what we put up on
the dark web cuz they get blocked
worldwide I give - I know
can't even dispute it and our patrons
were like what is this like we don't
want to see this kind of content so why
we lose like 30 patrons every month yeah
it's like my hero academia tighten snuff
film
you know like gone yeah I thought that's
what most people pledge for yeah I can't
see anywhere else
you know it's exclusive well I think
we've said all that needs to be said
congratulations to all you hard-working
people that work I mean this is a major
accomplishment this started as like you
said it started as like self-funded yeah
exactly really really cool so make sure
to oil it oil yourself sure - is this a
order some toilet paper on Amazon and
bingo - yeah
binge is just watched it in the
bathrooms and I ever had to stop I've
never I think the joke we got was much
better than that let's get all the jokes
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell seriously if you're
going to comic-con would love it if you
could attend this panel horde and grant
theater show premieres Friday July 19th
that is
and the panel itself is so you can
either go watch the show or go to the
panel but the show will be there forever
so you know go to the panel and please
say hi John will be in the crowd
cheering only one clapping when I show
up on stage I'm excited for that
follow Katrina on social media she is
occasionally in the dark web - mm-hmm
don't want to ask why